christopher reeve never gave up hope
that he and others would one day walk
again and last night was the 25th
anniversary of a magical evening for the
Christopher and Dana Reeve Foundation
and that is where Cameron Mathison sat
down with Christopher son Matthew for a
rare one-on-one interview
they had a fierce determination and a
dedication to the cause and he found
himself in a position that you might not
have chosen but he definitely chose to
embrace it
Christopher was passionate about finding
a cure for spinal cord injuries now 35
year old Matthew and his siblings are
continuing to raise money for research
is this one of the ways that you and
your family helped keep his legacy alive
we grew up you know with him in a
wheelchair you know a spinal foot injury
doesn't just happen to the individual it
happens to the whole family and
everyone's lives are affected my sister
and I and now my brother on the board of
directors we're at this amazing
threshold in research for the spinal
cord injury community Christopher and
Robin Williams were very close friends
and I had a specially team moment to
show Matthew check this out 1982 so how
did this evening go warren piece's
shorter I think it's d-day a stage by
Frederick's of Hollywood great it did
Robin having an impact on you and your
life as well as yeah absolutely I mean I
knew Robin my whole life and our
families are always been very close
their relationship was more than
friendship
in the Brotherhood Robin's son Zachary
and the actors ex-wife Marsha attended
the gala along with Meryl Streep and
Meredith Vieira and we all remember when
we'll read was just a little guy now the
23 year old is a reporter for ESPN thank
you to the Miami Heat for repping these
jerseys it truly is an honor and a
privilege for me to get to work at ESPN
I can't wait to see what happens well
last year's event raised a million
dollars and every penny is so valuable
it truly can change the life